that that was always something hard for
me because i have a really strong work
ethic like my whole life that's like the
one thing that i've always been
complimented on this i work like very
hard at what i do and it is hard to find
a guy that like works harder than me to
be honest like it's it's difficult and
it's always harder because
like men don't really value that as much
as women do well not hard work yeah yeah
like work ethic
i don't
you just said if a girl is working at
like like the checkout
[Music]
men have great work ethic yes they do
right and like i'm saying like like as a
girl like i i work very hard like i'm
always like since i was a kid that was
the one thing like i've always been
complimented right i'm a very hard
worker right and i said like sometimes
it's hard like in dating because that
isn't really valued to men i feel like
like i feel like it's working yeah yeah
they don't care one of the things that
boxing
exactly but it's like um
i don't know sometimes you kind of wish
it was but it's just not how it is no
it's not i understand that it's really
not okay but it's because it's like like
then the guys that have that work ethic
do you know what that's valuable to you
other women yeah i know i know
it's valuable valuable to you yeah it's
not very good oh i know
yeah like work
and then it's like it can be harder and
dating like as a girl that like works
hard because you can't you can't turn
that off that's just how that's how i am
right and so but then it's like you're
competing for an even smaller pool of
guys no you work very hard you like
incredibly like i see you work all the
time
but like it's like you're competing for
like a smaller a smaller group of guys
because who wants to be with a guy that
who wants to be the guy that doesn't
work as hard as you you know right right
yeah yeah right right ambition so the
man that you're looking for yeah needs
to have the same work ethic as you yeah
yeah i would say ambition is a good word
or is even just like um but trying to be
better than
what you yeah what you were served or
what you were even getting i always say
i would marry a coach if if he was a
coach and like that's not a high paying
career but if he he yeah if he he's
passionate about and he works hard at it
i don't care if he's a musician a coach
like i i have less money than me that's
fine i have family money i don't care
like i don't so so what does that matter
to me i just want to know like
i'm a millionaire [ __ ]
not not now i'm not like a brat like i
don't have anything now but i know like
at some point i'll inherit something
right
i think is how hard he works and how
much he wants to invest to make that
thing that he's working for yeah
yeah yeah
what's the point of him maybe i'm
working for that thing if he's you know
just there just to like do the
conventional [ __ ] like oh let me just
get this like to just just get a check
yeah like you don't want to make it
better than what you already got like
whatever yeah
yeah yeah yeah
yeah but that's but i feel like it's not
100 hypergamy it's just like you know
it's the motivation and just like
wanting to make something that you have
you want a guy that works harder it's
like like women women date up so so
hypergamy just means we day up so i want
to date a guy that works harder than me
or at least as hard as i do so that
that's high perk me
and maybe maybe i'll be one of these
like 35 and single child
i am not
what if you met a guy on your level the
same level as you as you motivated the
standard that you are yeah okay
what's the cat that be good for you
would that be okay for you yeah
i think i feel like that would because
you know we'd be there to push each
other to be
like better than what we are
i think that's what i want i don't i
don't want to be so i sell hiccups but i
don't want to just be in this steady
pace and be like okay like let's just
keep going so do you think do you feel
like you're at a steady pace
right now i i'm i think i'm going up you
know i was and you've got a guy that's
on the same
you have a guy on the same level that's
reaching for something more yes whatever
you're thinking and feeling and reaching
for you find a guy on that same level
yes is that good enough for you yes or
do you want the guy that's
higher than that
right no i wouldn't you know
socially
and economically
he's a business owner he's a you know i
mean he's he's doing a little easier
he's doing a little bit more well than
you he's not at university he's
made his business he's done all this
kind of stuff he's already established
himself okay like i would do you prefer
that guy
over the guy that's
on your level
i would say you know i wouldn't mind
having someone at my same level and
working towards the same goal okay and
at that point if i find the same two
people i would say that depends on how
much
chemistry you have with that person to
find students you know i think without i
don't know you right
i think you choose a guy
who is higher up you think so why
because
hypergamy is a thing
and so hypergame is a thing and so
all right all right so so
so okay so you got two guys that you
like right
just what if i click with one more thing
you click with the guidance you click
with the guy that's
normal let's say for whatever better
term normal then you click with the guy
who is
a business owner multi-millionaire maybe
etc
etc
who are you picking
if you were saying everything else was
the same yeah if everything you clicked
with this guy and you clicked with that
guy like personality wise family-wise
everything you click with them both the
same
higher up then hypergame is a thing you
haven't men it's the same thing with men
100 percent it's like everyone everyone
i'm not saying it's a bad thing i'm not
saying it's a bad thing no no no
everything
but i'm saying like everyone wants to
accept that everyone wants the best deal
they can get exactly i just the
difference is women lie to each other
and say they can get a better deal than
they can get that's the difference where
men will men will be honest to be like
look she's out of your league bro
what not a lot of men like a lot of them
men will be honest with each other like
no no
oh my god yes they do more than if it oh
my god
we will tell them if they've got a
[ __ ] booger in their nose we will
tell them if the girl that they're
seeing ain't the right girl for them we
will tell them everything
because
we were telling if they're getting fat
bro bro you're getting fat bro like you
were a guy in gym like what the [ __ ]
but the thing is no no we would do it no
they do i'm lying the thing is women
don't tell the women lie to other women
look at body positivity let's just start
there come on
lizzo is a flashlight she's she should
have shot at chris hemsworth we all know
damn well chris hemsworth is not
responding to lizzo he's going to go
find them lizzo is a fat individual
right by standards people like yeah
buzzy body positivity it's like come on
like we just
you lied to other women that's what